- I have never heard of this before. Ever.
(upbeat music)
- Is this a Japanese Will
Wonka sort of (beep)?
- We majored in art stuff.
So...
- I'm imagining edible Legos.
I'm actually really excited.
Wait. This becomes a tentacle?
- Oh, my God. This one's
Coca-Cola flavored.
- Move this goo in there.
(candy snapping)
- This kind of reminds
me of that Play-Doh kit
where you make the people's hair.
- Aw, yeah.
- [Girl in Pink] You have to have like
nimble fingers for this.
- [Girl in Dog T-shirt]
I'm like so surprised.
- It looks like a Pintrest fail.
- So, this is what the package looks like
and this is what our product looks like.
- Nailed it.
- [Girl lin Grey] Look at them
all. They're best friends.
- I didn't expect there
to be so many steps
to making this candy.
- In America, it just comes
in the gummy bear shape.
- Ooh. Ice cream-esque things.
- (laughs) I'm excited about this one.
- Kind of looks like the
candy world in Wreck It Ralph.
- Oh, it does.
- They're so little.
- These are so cute.
- This is measuring.
This thing is a measuring tool.
- I love that you can
decide for all of this.
I was just gonna wing it.
- Ooh! It smells like cake.
- Mmm. This is good.
- [Girl in Pink] Oh,
(beep). Look, it's icing up.
- We're behind on the times, America.
- Our toys are so dumb compared to this.
- Oh, we squeeze it on here
and we do like the little--
- Oh! That's awesome.
- This is the perfect thing
for like having a friend over.
- Cut the tip.
(laughs)
- [Girl in Grey] Oh, yeah.
This is what Dairy Queen taught me.
- [Girl in Purple] Oh, (beep).
(gasps)
(laughs)
- Ice cream it out.
- Yes.
- Girl, that's kind of phallic. (laughs)
- [Girl in Dog T-shirt] It was pretty.
- [Man in Red] You ruined everything.
- Oh, wait. Is it not good?
(laughs) Oh, no.
- Is it good?
- It's pure sugar.
That's great.
(laughs)
- It tastes like wet sand.
(candy crunching)
It looks great.
Tastes like (beep).
- Mmm.
- Wow.
- Oh, God. The directions are--
- There's so many directions.
- I feel like it's just
moulding them though, right?
Like, we don't have that many options.
- It's gonna taste like toothpaste.
- Where is this?
- Orange is this square.
- Which orange? Big one or little one?
- [Girl in Dog T-shirt] This one?
- [Man in Red] This
looks like the broccoli.
- This is broccoli?
- We gotta put water in there, right?
- I know. I just don't know how much.
- Pink. Pink goes in the pineapple thing.
- Blue is supposed to go in here, I think.
- Yes, because the grey goes in--
- No, wait. This says
the red goes in there.
- What?
- You know what? I think
the blue goes in there
and then the red goes in there.
Oh! They're becoming gelatinous.
I want this to look good.
If this looks bad, I'm gonna cry.
- [Girl in Dog T-shirt] Ease it out--
Oh, God.
- [Man in Red] Oh, no.
- [Girl in Glasses]
He's a little deformed,
but that's okay.
- [Girl in Dog T-shirt]
It looks like snot.
- The whole spectrum of snot.
- [Girl in Grey] I think
we did pretty well.
- [Girl in Glasses] I
think that we killed it.
We crushed it, it looks like there.
- In our defense, we don't speak Japanese
and it's really hard.
- If I had the time set aside,
I feel I could do a really good job.
This one was a rough one.
- Props to Japan because if I was a parent
and you're gonna give me candy,
at least give them a candy
that will keep them occupied
for like a half an hour.
That's a great idea.